un mode économie pour commencer
aujourd'hui jeudi 7 juillet gfi
informatique 8e entreprises des services
du numérique français organisé une
journée portes ouvertes recrutement à
saint quentin en yvelines
une quarantaine de candidats ont été
présélectionnés pour l'événement il
était amené à rencontrer les équipes de
recrutement techniques et commerciales
30 postes sont à pourvoir d'ici la fin
2016 sur la région ile de france pour
renforcer les activités applications
services infrastructures et conseil du
groupe
marlène escure directrice recrutement
france chez gfi informatique nous
explique l'intérêt de ce job dating
l'idée de ce type d'événement c'est de
concentrer sur l'après midi en tout cas
et début de soirée des équipes à la fois
recrutement opérationnelle et
commerciale et de s'assurer qu'on puisse
attirer le candidat sur ce procès ce qui
serait raccourcie puisque il va
rencontrer une partie des des personnes
qui interviennent dans des procédures de
recrutement sur cet événement